rob's with us in virginia beach hi rob
how are you
hey mr dave hey ken how you guys doing
great man how can we help
um so unfortunately i got a divorce
recently
about a year and a half ago and i'm on
baby step two currently
and um i co-signed for the car that she
currently drives
and as per the divorce decree she's
responsible for the payments and she's
been making them
um except for a couple which have
negatively impacted my credit but i was
just wondering do i need to add
like our joint car loan in
baby step 2 as part of my debt or
do i go by the divorce decree and let
her continue making payments and just
kind of monitor it
well every time she doesn't make a
payment on time it's showing up gonna
show up on your credit report
yes sir she's only done that once
fortunately but
it hit it hit pretty hard it dropped at
about 75 points so
um that was about a year ago and i was
just wondering
um in baby step two if i need to add her
car on the list or not
no you don't but you need to get that
car paid off
and get it off your name so how are you
gonna do that
how are you gonna do that i tried to i
tried to do a transfer of equity but her
credit score isn't good enough so it
defaulted back into my name and she also
tried to refinance
in just her name um but unfortunately
she's the type of personality that if i
start helping her make payments or make
put even a dollar towards it she'll um
stop paying it completely
so that's just what i'm trying to avoid
because so what what is the balance on
the car
is about 23 000 still good lord no you
do
so what should have happened in the
divorce decree was the sale of the car
yes sir it should have been a forced
sale and so
um
what do you make a year currently i make
eighty thousand i'm a disabled veteran
so i'm at a hundred percent right now
with the i'm trying to
eventually get a home next year so i'm
trying to be debt free this year
because um it's still counting as long
as that car loan
issue as long as that car loan exists
you're not debt-free
yes sir because there's your name on it
yes sir
oh i'm sorry well thank you for your
service um
thank you for your support i uh what
does she make
um she was a server last night spoke to
her we're not on speaking terms it was
kind of a nasty divorce unfortunately
so last i know she makes around 23
i believe okay so she has a car she
can't afford
yes sir i think she's too stubborn to go
ahead and admit that and sell it
so that well um
what i would do what i would do is if
she misses another payment
i would uh hire an attorney and drag her
back in before the judge and ask the
judge
motion the court for the car to be sold
yes sir as soon as she misses one
payment
okay because like i said i'm trying to
i'm tired of renting
and well the bottom line is that's
what's going to help her
is to get rid of the car and it's also
going to help you
because she she cannot if she's making
twenty five thousand dollars a year she
doesn't need a twenty two thousand
dollar car payment
that just doesn't once i paid off yeah
sorry guys yeah
and so and and i don't want you to pay
the car off i want you to force her to
sell it now if you could convince her
that it was in her best interest to sell
it because it is
um or if you have anyone that you know
that can speak into her life
that could convince her um
to sell the car it would be in her best
interest
it also by the way would be in yours but
i mean
actually yeah if she gets a hit at all
that is in my best interest she's less
likely to do it basically
well i mean it's obvious it's in your
best interest you owe the money on the
you're on the car loan she knows that
but that's not the motivation here the
motivation is
she if she's got to get rid of this car
payment because
and she can't and so it's killing her
it's eating her alive and so she's going
to miss another payment
if you can't get word to her or get her
to somehow
listen to sell the car just go ahead and
have some money set aside for an
attorney
and the first time she misses a payment
immediately petition
follow file a motion with the court to
have the car sold
because she's not the court decree the
divorce decree demands that she pays the
payments and she's not paying them
and she's damaging you and when you get
before the judge you can say
oh by the way you're on it she makes
twenty thousand dollars a year she's got
twenty two thousand dollar car payment
it's not good for her your honor and he
would look at her or she will look
at her and say oh yeah you need to sell
this car kid
that's a bad deal and they'll they'll
help her
adjust her attitude that's one thing
judges are pretty good at
they take great great pride in that well
i mean a lot of them
honestly at that level a lot of judges
are not it's not like tv they really do
care
and they actually will look at you and
go you know that
they use wisdom oh it's like the parent
many people have never had exactly
exactly i mean uh you know we do a lot
of work with the uh uh
the foster care system in tennessee and
so we've got to know a lot of the
juvenile court judges and stuff and
i got to tell you they they're the best
social workers on the planet i mean they
really
uh they care and they've got the power
to do something about it too
so uh it's um just it's just wisdom
and this this poor girl is not being
wise it's not good for her